[Music]
on this sunday night
teachers push back on back to school
plans
some say they won't be returning to work
if class sizes aren't reduced in
september
i don't envy them at all i feel for them
a river ride
in hot water why this annual float down
sparked fears of an international
incident plus
belarus on the brink
the country's largest ever protest and
warnings of a military
response and a remarkable rescue from
the jaws
of death
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
jeff semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us this is shaping up to be a critical
week in defining exactly what
school will look like come september
with several provinces making final
adjustments to their reopening plans
now at this point in places with
relatively few cases of covet 19
classes will resume with few
restrictions bc
saskatchewan and manitoba will mostly
rely on placing students in groups or
cohorts
to limit their exposure in ontario
quebec new brunswick and calgary
some grades will be required to bring
masks but
class sizes and the ability to
physically distance
remain a key concern in many parts of
the country
and some teachers say that if they don't
feel safe they simply won't be returning
to the classroom heather urix west
reports
when molly rayne dale begins grade five
this fall
she won't be returning to her usual
school yeah i'm disappointed that i
won't be able to go and see my friends
again
but i do want to keep my family safe we
were very torn
about but because you want to make the
right decision for your child but we
have decided to keep molly home
and and do a homeschool program at home
it's a decision now facing parents
across canada
but it's not their decision alone
teachers will soon have to head back to
class too
and according to teachers unions across
the country many educators are worried
that returning to school could put them
at an increased risk for covert covid19
many of those teachers that have
registered complaints or concerns have
are immunocompromised themselves and are
worried about what this means for them
directly or their family members who are
also
or maybe immunocompromised teachers
unions in ontario saskatchewan and
alberta say members are now weighing
their options
looking at whether they have the right
to refuse work if concerns related to
their health and safety
are not addressed we put out seven
priority areas that we would like to see
addressed in the real queen of schools
and i know that we need to address
things like class size and cohorting and
social distancing at school
the alberta teachers association
requested an emergency meeting with the
province
saturday that meeting will happen
midweek across the country back to
school plans seem to be evolving by the
day
ontario announced more funding friday
saskatchewan plans to announce more
money for school districts on monday
as well as school districts work to
adapt to the evolving framework it means
teachers likely won't know what their
covet 19 classroom health and safety
conditions
will be like until school returns the
way that our legislation works here in
alberta is that you have to go back to
work first to see
and we'll have to see where we are with
that in an unsafe work environment work
can be refused adding one more layer of
uncertainty to the school year
when classes resume will teachers feel
safe enough to stay
heather urex west global news calgary
an unauthorized annual event that
typically attracts hundreds of people to
the river that connects ontario and
michigan
planned to go ahead this year despite
the canada u.s border closure
but that event didn't quite turn out as
planned
for more than 30 years americans and
some canadians have hopped in their
inner tubes for the port huron
float down law enforcement on both sides
of the border urged people not to take
part this year
citing concerns over covid19 well those
warnings
and the poor weather appear to deter
many floaters
however the local mayor says the event
still comes
at a high cost because of the weather
this morning and
some of the warnings that the attendance
is lower than the donald trump rally
so what's happening here is still going
to cost the taxpayers 100 to 200
thousand dollars
even with the lower turnout this year
the rcmp plans to remain on site and the
river will remain closed to other
traffic
until 10 o'clock tonight worldwide the
number of confirmed cases of covid 19
is growing faster than ever in a 24-hour
period more than 294 000 people
tested positive for the virus that's the
highest daily total since the pandemic
began
there are now more than 21 million
confirmed cases of covid19 around the
world
with about a quarter of those cases in
the united states and south korea just
reported its biggest covid19 outbreak in
five months
the country added 279 new cases today
mainly due to local infections in the
greater seoul area
linked to churches schools and
restaurants there's now concern about
further spread after
thousands of anti-government protesters
rallied in the city
yesterday and tens of thousands of
people gathered in the capital of
belarus today in what's believed to be
the largest protest in that country's
history
the unrest started last week after
president alexander lukashenko
claimed a landslide election victory his
regime is now facing its biggest threat
since coming to power nearly three
decades ago
and as redmond shannon explains russia
is now offering
to help the biggest
rally yet tens of thousands of
belarusians
dressed in the opposition colors of
white and red
from exile in lithuania svetlana
takanovskiya put out the call for the
event
opposition supporters say she was the
rightful election winner
but they are no longer just protesting
last week's result
which they say was rigged by president
alexander lukashenko
but also the alleged police brutality
that followed
new video shows the moment the first of
two protesters killed
this week fell to the ground in front of
riot police
authorities say he was holding an
explosive device
the video is unclear but it shows the
man with blood
coming from his chest his partner
insists
he was unarmed and was shot
also on sunday lukashenko addressed a
smaller group of his supporters
telling them nato is ready to invade
belarus
something nato denies lukashenko spoke
to russian president vladimir putin
sunday
the kremlin now offering the belarusian
leader military support
if required i can't wait i i checked the
mail every day even though
calgary man rick gove has been living in
the north of the country with his
belarusian girlfriend
but left to renew his visa a few weeks
ago there's one night where i called her
and she's crying
she said that there were grenades going
off like 400 meters from our house
and it's been really hard i just wish i
could be there
with her anastasia carrickevich says
police have become
less aggressive as the week has gone on
with every next day
i would say that the fear is going
lower and lower we have it less and less
and less each day
we are feeling stronger and more
powerful
[Applause]
if nationwide industrial strikes resume
monday pressure will only increase on
lukashenko
his next move could be critical redmond
shannon global news
london one of two canadians killed in
that massive blast in beirut earlier
this month
has now been identified three-year-old
alexandra
nager died in hospital from a head
injury she suffered during the explosion
today global news spoke to the young
girl's grandfather who lives near beirut
and raced to be by her side in hospital
he says his granddaughter was at home
with her mother
and they were living in a building that
faces the port and were blown away by
the force of the blast
he also revealed the family was
preparing to move back to montreal
later this year they were already
planning to move to morial by the end of
september and
unfortunately happened this explosion
before that they were blown
from their place and she couldn't hold
alexandra anymore
they were you know under doors
piano and and they rushed her to the
hospital
she had a severe injury in her head and
they did all they can
that blast in beirut leveled buildings
and overturned cars more than two
kilometers away from where 2700 tons of
ammonium nitrate erupted
canadian aid agencies are now working on
the ground in beirut
and warned that basic supplies of food
and water
are now running out crystal gomansing
reports
it's just a few basics non-perishables
to help people get by but the lines are
long
this mother of two says it's not a lot
enough for a week
she calls the process humiliating
many are frustrated and feel hopeless
the canadian red cross is on the ground
working with local agencies
assessing the country's needs the full
extent of the situation is still unknown
but officials are worried about the days
ahead
fresh vegetables fruits
fish meat all of this is very difficult
to
to to get and the prices are on the rise
the inflation as you know was already
quite high before this but now it's
going up because of course the demand is
going up
according to the world food program
about 80 percent of lebanon's food
supply
came through the beirut port the
country's wheat flour supply is
dwindling and may only last
a few more weeks workers are busy
setting up temporary cranes and storage
facilities at the port food shipments
are on their way
to bolster the food supply pictures
can't describe
the reality that is here nothing but
pure devastation
the blast on august 4th not only
destroyed the port but grocery stores
cafes homes
even hospitals three are no longer
functional and three others have been
badly damaged
violin derosier says the red cross is
seeing people
never considered vulnerable before
because
every aspect of life has been affected
and we caught a real life example
that's power cuts in beirut
okay so you're witnessing what we are
experiencing
several times a day it's coming back
power food shelter there are many issues
that need to be addressed
helping beirut get back on its feet will
be a long-term endeavor
crystal commansing global news london
to the united states now and a growing
controversy ahead of november's
presidential election
there are now reports the u.s postal
service is removing
mail sorting machines today trump denied
his administration
is deliberately trying to undermine the
postal service's operations
at a time when demand for mail-in
ballots is surging due to the pandemic
as jennifer johnson explains it's all
happening on the eve
of the democrats national convention
top democrats are sounding the alarm and
returning to washington
august 24th hoping to question
postmaster general lewis dejoy
after allegations mail sorting machines
are being removed
from post offices ahead of november's
election
millions of mail-in ballots are expected
to be cast due to the covet-19 pandemic
this is the last thing we should be
doing is politicizing
the postal service dejoy a top trump
campaign donor was appointed by u.s
president donald trump in may
in june postal workers reported some
machines were being removed
with hundreds more slated to go white
house officials are now making this
pledge
there's no sorting machines that are
going offline between now and the
election
the u.s postal service inspector general
has also launched an investigation into
the controversy
even some republicans are concerned
about possible voter suppression
we want people to vote it is essential
in my view
for a nation which is the leading nation
of democratic nations in the world
the leader of the free world for us to
show that elections can be held in a
free
and fair manner the issue igniting
democrats as they begin their virtual
national convention monday
formally nominating democrats joe biden
and kamala harris to try and take back
the white house
we have got to do everything we can to
come together to defeat donald trump
when my view is the most dangerous
president in the modern history of this
country
sanders and former first lady michelle
obama are the keynote speakers monday
night
biden speaks thursday night likely
focusing on president trump's
mishandling of the covet 19 pandemic
which has killed over 170 thousand
americans so far
and plunged the u.s into its worst
economic crisis
since the great depression jennifer
johnson global news
washington coming up serb is coming to a
close
sparking calls for a guaranteed basic
income
in canada
welcome back since the start of the
pandemic eight and a half
million canadians who lost income due to
the lockdown
have received the canada emergency
response benefit or serb
but that benefit is set to come to an
end next month
the federal ndp wants the serb to become
permanent
in the form of a guaranteed basic income
michael couture has more that's what
i've got for 700
this is my this is my part of the house
rebecca guzzo was renting the upstairs
of a home in hamilton
because it's all she can afford she's
still trying to get back on her feet
after being homeless
and having her kids in social care and
it was a vicious circle because the
social work student just didn't have the
necessities of life
if my basic needs were met during my
most
difficult struggles i would have been
able to continue through with college
i would have been able to continue
through doing my social work it's why
she's so supportive of an ndp motion to
convert the candidate emergency response
benefit
into a guaranteed basic income for those
who need it most
many seniors living in canada
do not have a livable income i know many
seniors in my riding choose between
rent and medication gazan says the
pandemics show the resources are there
to help canadians
in 2017 ontario started a basic income
pilot project in three cities
but it was cancelled when the
progressive conservatives swept into
power
the federal minister of social
development was unavailable for an
interview
but in a statement a spokesperson said
the design and implementation of
provincial programs like
basic income is up to the provinces
themselves
through our investments we have reached
the lowest level of poverty in canadian
history
by lifting over one million canadians
out of poverty
adding the government will explore all
options to help people join the middle
class we
now have a deficit of a third of a
trillion
dollars management professor ian lee
worries about the cost of a basic
income program especially since the
ndp's plan
would be on top of existing social
services
the parliamentary budget officer
estimates a guaranteed basic
income could cost up to 96 billion
dollars
for a six-month period that's in
addition to the hundreds of billions of
dollars the government has already spent
on emergency pandemic aid packages
i don't know of any serious person who
is saying that the government of canada
can run up deficits of a half a trillion
dollars
indefinitely forever into the future lee
thinks a good middle ground could be a
revamped employment insurance program
that could make sure fewer canadians get
left behind
mike lacrouter global news ottawa
the canada revenue agency just shut down
all
online services after thousands of
accounts were breached in cyber attacks
anyone trying to log into a cra account
is met with this message telling them
the service is not available
that means right now canadians are not
able to apply online for emergency
covid19 funding such as serb
hackers were able to access thousands of
accounts using a technique called
credential stuffing it relies on
databases of previously stolen
login information still ahead how a
fistfight with a shark
saved a woman's life
in china zoo goers gathered to give
their well wishes to the world's oldest
living panda in captivity
xixing turned 38 today the panda
equivalent of more than 110 human years
to mark the special occasion her zoo
threw her a birthday party attended by
dozens of panda lovers
now according to the zoo xi jing is one
of only 30 giant pandas in the world
to live past the age of 30. she looks
great for her age
a heroic husband in australia is making
waves tonight
after he sprung into action jumping off
his surfboard to save his wife
by repeatedly punching a shark the shark
attack happened saturday at shelley
beach in new south wales
a popular place to swim and surf the man
punched
the three meter long great white shark
several times in the face
until it released the woman from its
jaws
it hit her like a like with a force and
threw off the board
and so you get this kind of like a punch
or something i just saw the water
splash and punch and i knew
instantaneously just from
seeing other things like that so i just
started paddling oh
you see the mother of your child and
your support
everything that's who you are and
so you just react wow remind me not to
pick a fight with that guy
the 35 year old woman was airlifted to
hospital with severe cuts to her right
calf and the back of her thigh which
he's expected to make a full
recovery up next the show must go on
how concerts are making a clever
comeback during the pandemic
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back it's easy to see why the
music industry has been
singing the blues during this pandemic
around the globe many concerts and
festivals have been cancelled to curb
the spread of covid19
but as parts of the world ease those
restrictions some event organizers are
finding new creative ways to ensure the
show
can go on safely felicia perillo
has more
gone are the days where thousands of
people pack into a single space
standing shoulder to shoulder and side
by side
music festivals and concerts that draw
large crowds
will probably be off limits for a while
and so event organizers around the world
are coming up with different ways for
people to have
a bit of fun take this concert
in the uk for example around 2500 fans
gathered at a park in newcastle
to watch a show by musician sam fender
but instead of people standing all
together groups of five
are separated on a metal platform at the
arena
meanwhile here at home people are also
experimenting with different solutions
fans in toronto were treated to an
outdoor concert thursday night
drive-in style music-goers enjoyed the
wreck laws from the comfort of their
cars
definitely think it's going to be a
little strange we're kind of far away
back here
but it'll be interesting for sure the
new venue is located by the city's
waterfront
all summer long it'll host fans for live
concerts sports games
and special movie screenings i'm really
excited to experience this it's
definitely once in a lifetime right now
[Music]
another once in a lifetime experience a
new festival inspired by the pandemic
it's called krugerfest the event allowed
for people in regina to book a private
hotel room and attend a music festival
from their balcony we put our stage on
the rooftop of a parkage structure
that's adjacent to
uh the doubletree by hilton in regina
the hotel has 108 rooms with
balconies that overlook the rooftop
stage that we've built
morrison says tickets start at 600 which
includes a room
a meal and some concerts more than that
proceeds from each ticket
will go to a local food bank so it's
basically like having a private box
suite at a stadium
or an arena everybody's kind of a vip
and everybody gets their own private
space so
morrison's advice enjoy and embrace
these new experiences
because who knows we may actually miss
them
once they're gone
[Music]
felicia perella global news montreal
and that's global national for this
sunday i'm jeff semple tonight's your
canada is greenwich national park in
prince edward island robin gill will be
with you here tomorrow
have a great night
you